I think it was Tony Curtis who once said
everything and anything you want to do
you do it in Vegas
you can pretty much do it all day and
all night if you want to and that means
if you know how to live in Vegas you can
have the best time but to know how to
live here is an art and not many people
know how to do
this guy is your man when it comes to
nightlife he's your best contact in town
waiting lists in velvet ropes don't
apply to his guests whatever you want
whenever you need it you will deliver
each time we meet he tells me about the
city's guests who came before me to
inspire a great night out you know what
something tells me we're gonna have a
lot of fun with this guy the night's
darks edgy just a drink but see bubbles
followed by a goodnight tradition that
truth be told always served as well and
then continues with a quick tour of the
city through the reflections of a black
car window we have a transitional
moments or as I like to call it a
low-key ride a friend and just like you
wouldn't die the sports car empty
you should also never go out before
eating great tennis great company after
that this trip brings you to the Dan
table but just make sure you don't get
lost in the lights on the way in and on
the way out now you're probably asking
yourself why I'm alone you see the thing
is once you've had the best time you
need a moment to take it all in at the
end of the day or should I say night the
best way to see Vegas is through your
very own arts and tomorrow a new
adventure of knocking at the door